so welcome everybody
to
refinement of rodent anesthesia through
appropriate selection and use of
physiological monitoring
so i think most of you guys already know
that at the end of the presentation
we're going to have a q a session
so i'll be more than happy to address
any questions you might have at that
time
so one of the things that you guys might
be aware of that within the last few
years
there are several publications
that are addressing that animal studies
are put predictors of what happens in
clinics and obviously media picked up on
it and a lot of it
there's specific reasons why that is
true
obviously not in all cases but in some
cases
so one of the things few things that
have been identified why this happens so
one you have a poorly designed
experiments
you have poorly conducted experiments
and that's where the surgical procedures
and physiological monitoring are lack of
will fit into and we'll talk about that
and then you have poorly analyzed
experiments
so
i believe that we can change that and
the animal studies
will and are good predictors
of what's going to happen in clinics but
we do have to improve on those three
aspects and today we're going to address
how can we improve
on well
conducted studies
so these well conducted studies will
allow us to standardize and reproduce
our studies
not just
within the same lab but between labs
which is going to
increase the ability to translate these
studies into clinics and it also
improves animal welfare and i think
that's one of the really big reasons why
we're all here
so one of the things that is very
different in the lab animal community is
that for large animals they're talking
about dogs cats
non-human primates we pretty much
utilize implementing what is a gold
standard when it comes to physiological
monitoring in most cases
but when it comes to rodents
you know not until recently none of that
was really implemented
and obviously if we're going to be doing
a
gastrointestinal bypass for example in a
mouse
we should
implement the same type of monitoring
that we do in larger species
so within next 15 minutes or so
we'll talk about anesthetic options that
are out there
the effect
on studies
depending on anesthetic that you decide
to use
when i talk about how can we find
anesthesia when we utilize physiological
monitoring
and also how do you select
appropriate physiological monitoring
what's appropriate for your specific
study
and also i hope that i can convince you
that with implementation on
physiological monitoring you can really
decrease the confounding factors
which again leads to better translation
of these studies into clinics
so
we have really three options
for anesthesia
and a lot of
the information that we have implemented
at our facility is with work with paul
flack now who
for those who don't know him he's really
the person to go to when it comes to
anesthesia and analgesia in laboratory
animal field
so the options
that we have
we have injectable
and inhalation agents and then obviously
we also have
the combination option which is really
the balanced anesthesia we're not going
to get into that today too much but in
the end that's the option that you
should
utilize if you can
so
why do we care about monitoring
anesthesia
so anesthesia can impact animal welfare
it introduces confounding factors and
we'll go into the details how that
happens
which increases variation within a study
and between a study
which in the long run increases the
number of animals that we really need to
obtain good statistical diet
inappropriate anesthesia increases
number of animals
due to morbidity and mortality
so improving anesthesia
really allows us to refine
and reduce the number of animals that we
utilize which again it goes along with
the three r's which were all strived for
words
so increased morbidity and mortality
from inappropriate anesthetic mythology
again will increase the number of
animals that are used along in the long
run
so implementing physiological
and anesthesia monitoring will allow us
to
limit these factors and decrease the
number of animals that we will need
so
injectable anesthetics are very popular
when we
work with rodents
and the reason for that is that are
simple to administer
there's a wide range of agents that we
can utilize they're available to us
but with that
with this wide range of agents we also
have a wide range of side effects from
these agents which again it's going to
be difficult to reproduce our studies
if they have these wide ranges and also
it varies with different strains of mice
and rats
and the impact that these anesthetics
have
so
again the problem with these anesthetics
with injectables is the variability
they're not administered intravenously
so when we introduce them for example
intraperitoneally
in our workshops where we actually
utilize a blue dye
um and where participants are injecting
the blue dye and then we monitor and
check where the dye actually goes we
find a 35 failure
rate with this technique meaning that uh
the dye
or an anesthetic case it goes into a
bladder the intestinal tract
or other organs within the abdominal
cavity where proflucknel has performed
similar assessments he has found that
there's a failure rate between 10 to 20
percent
so what are the advantages of inhalation
and aesthetics so they're simple to
administer
you have a very rapid induction and
recovery period when compared to
injectables
you have the ability to extend the
anesthesia so for example if i need to
do a procedure for two hours i don't
need to i can just just utilize and
adjust the gas and prolong the
anesthesia where with injectables you
have to assess the animal and re-inject
the animal which becomes challenging
because a lot of anesthetics will end up
staying on board for a long time
it's easy to change the depth of
anesthesia so we can adjust that very
quickly so we don't over anaesthetize
the animals
and then also we have a rapid recovery
again comparing to
injectable anesthetics
provides us with better control
we also provide oxygen at the same time
as we're
anesthetizing with
inhalation anesthetics
it is significantly safer because of all
the things i just mentioned
and it allows us to prove to preserve
the data of validity so it becomes
easier to repeat and reproduce our
studies
so here's an example of igor and johnson
where they have shown their recovery
from different
gas and aesthetics and as you can see
sibo fluorine diesel flooring is has the
right the most rapid one
so in our facility here we utilize sibo
fluorine for rodents as well as for
larger species and a lot of that has to
do with dr vince mendenhall who is
one of the surgeons here
and he has switched about a year or two
years ago to siva flooring and again the
animals
are induced quicker and are recovering
quicker as well
so why monitor anesthesia
so one the guide
states that we should so you have my and
this is the new guy the updated guide
which again this is something that has
not been addressed in the older version
of the guide
so here you have monitoring equipment
increases the safety and choices of
anesthetic agents for use in rodents and
other small species
careful surgical monitoring and timely
attention to problems increase the
likelihood of successful surgical
outcome so again we have to monitor
utilize physiologicals as anesthesia
monitoring to
improve the animal welfare and the
outcomes of these procedures
and a lot of times when we hear back
well i don't see any problems you know
the animals recover okay it might take
them a little bit longer to recover from
the anesthesia but they're do okay um
you know afterwards and after surgical
procedures but one of the things that if
you don't monitor if you don't look for
problems you're not going to find any
problems
or variables that are happening during
the surgical procedures
so also you want to monitor anesthesia
so you can actually see the effects the
anesthetics have
so for example very often
in gas anesthesia
the anesthetics are set to um 2.5
percent when you're working with
isofluorine
and
that oxygen is set to one liter per
minute
and
that's not always necessary what we
found when we do the gastric bypass
procedures which
it varies but they can take between an
hour to two hours in mice and rats we're
able to
decrease those levels from 2.5 to 1.5
percent of isoflorine and then 0.8
liters per minute again that's going to
depend on an aesthetic equipment that
you have
um but
we're not we were not going to be able
to do that unless we were monitoring the
anesthesia and the effects of anesthesia
of anesthetic that we're utilizing
and aesthetics also have an impact on
the research outcomes so here we have
just a list i'm not going to go through
these this is just to kind of point out
the injectable aesthetics have an impact
on different aspects
of the physiology uh the the immune
system so depending what type of study
you're going to be doing you should
consider these
and again some of these are dependent or
more anesthetic you provide the more
significant that effect it's going to
have on these values that you see here
same thing with
gas anaesthetics
so again the point here is that if you
don't monitor you're not going to be
able to see these and assess these
and here we have a comparison between
volatile injectable anaesthetics not a
comparison but really stating that again
in heart rate um there's a variability
as you can see depending what type of an
aesthetic you're using but if you're not
monitoring the heart rate you're never
going to know what that heart rate is
and with rodents that's not feasible to
do with the clinical assessments where
you just watch and count
or palpate for example
or use a stethoscope
so
we have talked about the effects of
anesthetics but now the other
aspects why we should monitor anesthesia
is to maintain adequate
depth of anesthesia want to make sure
that we're able to reproduce
what we have done in particular study it
allows us to identify problems during
the anesthetic period
and also it's good to have for data
collection so for example if out of all
the animals is an example the heart rate
ends up being let's say a hundred but
you have one animal you know that has a
significantly higher heart rate then you
can identify and mark it as an outlier
or potentially identifying a bullet from
the study
or assess and
adjust as you move forward with your
studies
so what to monitor during anesthesia
well again the depth of anesthesia you
want to monitor the respiratory function
the cardiovascular function and one of
the big things is the temperature and
we'll talk about the effects of
hypothermia on the animals as well
so
the equipment when you're choosing the
equipment you want to make sure the
monitoring equipment
you want to make sure that the
information that you receive is valuable
to you you can actually do something
about it
it has to be easy to utilize
again we have a lot of different folks
that are in our field so it's a lot
easier if it's easy to utilize and also
at the same time easy to teach someone
to utilize the equipment and it needs to
be reliable
so those are the three things that you
should consider and think about when
you're selecting the equipment you're
going to utilize
so
for cardiovascular system you can use
clinical monitoring in larger species
for example
you can check the pulse uh by
for by uh
but with your hand for example
um you can look for capillary refill
time and a dog or a cat you can also
assess the color of mucous membranes
but in rodents all those three things
are difficult if not impossible so this
is where
the physiological monitoring steps in
not to say that you should not pay
attention clinically to the animal as
well
so the electronic monitoring
you should try to monitor
not try but you should monitor the blood
pressure ecg
heart rate
and indirectly blood loss
but one of the things to remember that
if we want to monitor
these different aspects
you want to make sure that you also know
what the normals are or at least what
the range for the normal is if you don't
know the normals you're not going to be
able to decide if it's
is something abnormal or normal
so here are just some of the basic heart
rate examples for normals for this
species
so monitoring ecg
no matter the rate the rhythm and
electrical activity of the heart
and it's also going to depend for some
procedures you might not necessarily
need that
but for example when you do a thoracic
surgery it's something that you should
really have
because obviously when you're
manipulating in a thorax there's a heart
there and etc the other
has a pretty significant impact
on the animal the procedure that you're
going to be performing
pulsexometry
which measures tissue oxygen saturation
is also important
and one of the things to think about is
the sensors
that you're utilizing
so you know looking at five ten years
ago this was really challenging because
utilizing equipment that used in larger
species to mice and rats were almost
impossible but within last three to five
years
there are a lot of new developments and
equipment that's now specifically made
for mice and rats
but there's also some of the things to
think about
you want to make sure that the sensors
are the right size for them and one of
the things to consider that even
personally initially i really didn't
think about is when you have the
spring-loaded sensors i mean they make
it very easy because you just open it
and close it and put it on the animal's
limb or whatever you end up utilizing to
pull
but if it's spring loaded you can
actually introduce a lot of pressure
on that limb or that paw which can also
introduce
errors into your data collection
and also for placement you ideally want
to place the sensor and where the
pigment is the lightest
because that's when they work the best
so
you also have to know what's the normals
so for
oxygen saturation ideally when you're
performing anesthesia you want to keep
it at 97 to 100.
90 to 95 is still okay but you might
start seeing some problems but then when
you strap below 90 you stab hypoxia but
again if you're not monitoring the
saturation
you're never gonna see that and will the
animals with eighty-five percent
recover a lot of them will
but you also have to consider now what
kind of impact
the hypoxia has on the animal and on the
data that you're going to be collecting
after the procedure
so copnography
for a respiratory system
which measures the carbon dioxide in
expired and inspired gas is really
important and and they have not been
really a lot of
good tools available to us for that
um so
that's something when you're gonna
purchase the equipment make sure that it
does work appropriately
so you can actually utilize the data
that the capnography is going to
offer to you
and there are different models you have
the mainstream and the side stream
models and for rodents
the one that we're end up utilizing now
is a side stream model from
kent scientific
so now let's talk about hypothermia
so just to give you an example
when
we
went to different facilities and
assessing
gastric bypass procedures in
rodents
this was one of the biggest challenges
is keeping the animals warm so again
here we have a procedure that varies
between an hour to two hours
and what we found
that by just providing the right
right heat support to those animals on
average
we're able to increase the survivability
of the animals by 30
so obviously there's a huge impact on
the animals and then also the animals
that did survive
just because they survived didn't mean
that they didn't have any complications
because of hypothermia but again if
we're not monitoring the temperature and
the physiological
factors you're never going to know what
kind of impact it does have
hypothermia you know just a few things
here increases chance of myocardial infa
infarction it interferes with drug
metabolism so again your anesthetics
it's going to have a huge
impact on those and that's why animals
that cool down
or are hypothermic the recovery period
is significantly longer
but also there's an increased surgical
site infection with hypothermia it
impairs wound healing so it's one of the
things where we worked with the gastric
bypass
models which again a lot of animals just
rooted for diabetic they already have
problems with healing so now you're
adding hypothermia to it which even
complicates things farther
and you can also increase postoperative
bleeding
so
what's the normal so again this is
something you have to know because if
you don't even if you monitor you're not
going to be able to know what's
appropriate what's not
so how do we maintain temperature of the
animals there are a lot of different uh
pieces of equipment out there you have
heated water pads
which are uh
kind of selected
or recommended here united states the
electric heating pads are not
recommended here in u.s
but and
for example in uk
uh paul flacknell mentioned that that's
what's preferred in the end what's
really important though with both of
these units you're able to adjust the
temperature it doesn't set just too long
but you also want to make sure that
the heating pad
actually provides the right temperature
across the board
so one of the things that we can test
that is uh there's these sticky
thermometers that you can utilize for
your aquariums you can place those on
those heating pads and check where the
temperature is lower or higher and
it will change especially as the
equipment gets older so really doing a
quality assurance is extremely important
and a lot of times
we don't do that
in the lab animal field
hot air blowers are something that's
very commonly utilized in larger species
it works extremely well but we don't
have those available to us in
in rodents even trying the pediatric
models it just doesn't work well some of
the things that people also have
utilized as a bubble wrap or saran wrap
or even you know for example gloves with
heated
with water and heated
water but again the temperature you
can't monitor the temperature to drop
off very quickly when the glove raptures
the whole animal is going to get cooled
down so these really do not work well
and it's something that we do not
recommend
so one of the things also before you
actually provide
the the heat support you want to make
sure you can measure
uh the temperature so we work with uh
the sumner suite it's something that
can't scientific makes
and it allows us has a rectal
thermometer
that
monitors the animal's temperature
and then
the heating pad that it has
underneath the animal the temperature of
the heating pad goes up and down
depending on the temperature of the
animal
so again we allows us to monitor the
temperature but then it also adjusts to
the animal's temperature
and this is an infrared warming system
which
is fantastic because it's absorbed deep
in the body rather than just superficial
surface warming so a lot of times where
animals cool down to get them back we
increase the temperature of the heating
pads
but when you do that you can potentially
burn the animal and not potentially we
have actually seen that you can burn the
animal on the outside
and again because the animal is now
being heated throughout so with the
infrared warming system to a certain
extent that
addresses that question and you have
also low energy infrared rays which are
deep penetrating and absorbed throughout
throughout the body
so this is one of the
where we recommended what we use with
all of our
models
so what are some of the things that you
should think about when considering
purchasing um these different pieces of
equipment
so one you want to identify the
parameters you're going to be measuring
so for example if you're doing thoracic
surgery or heart surgery like a heart
transplant you might need more
monitoring options than you would if for
example
you're doing a catheter placement but
even with basic procedures for example
when we even do
subcutaneous
pump implantations we monitor
the physiological
aspects or parameters of the animal
because even in that short period of
time allows us to adjust our anesthesia
um it's going to also obviously look at
the animals they're utilizing so
if you're working with for example a
mouse
or pups in comparison to large rats
you're going to need different sensors
so those are things to consider also
what type of study you're going to be
doing um i cook protocols and guidelines
that you have at your institution and
then obviously also what the guide now
recommends
and also um we
i addressed the guy but obviously have
uh regulations in
uh european uh union now they have been
implemented
and those regulations are stricter than
what we have here in the u.s and in a
way that's a good thing because it
really enforces the utilization of
these physiological monitoring equipment
in our studies you want to identify also
space requirements
and also consider
future use with other animals
so for example maybe it's cheaper to
upgrade that system now versus upgrading
it uh it later
and so there's a question that came in
what is the blue dye that we use for
monitoring the injection that goes into
so it's a blue
ethylene blue
um die and so we don't uh
the animals are euthanized
at that uh during that that that
experiment or the traders training
sessions
so the other question comes up should we
ventilate or not mentally so what are
some of the pros of nod ventilate so one
you don't need any specialized equipment
um changes respiratory variables i will
indicate the anesthetic
depth
and it's beneficial to a cardiovascular
system
but so what are some of the cons
so hypoventilation is inevitable
same thing with hypercapnia you're going
to end up with acidemic animal
and again if you monitor the animals
you will see that this actually happens
if you're not monitoring you're never
going to know that these all of the
things that we just talked about are
actually occurring
you also have diffuse pulmonary
microatlactasia
hypoxia is possible
so
for us for our longer procedures we do
intubate our animals
and end up ventilating them
and it's become safer for the animal as
well as
for
uh
for the person performing the procedure
because there's a lower chance of the
anesthetics leaking into the environment
and one of the piece of quiz that we use
i mean there's obviously other ones out
there uh but we use mouse vent from kent
scientific which now is actually
implemented into the sumnos suite uh
which has also all the physiological
monitoring that we need
um so we like the unit you can move it
around very easily
it doesn't take up a lot of space in
which for example when we performing
when you're performing stereotactic
procedures space is is really very often
needed
so this unit is pretty cool and it works
for us but again we know there are other
units but we would recommend
ventilating your animals for us when we
for example do
gastric bypass procedures
we ventilate the animals and we also use
high frequency oscillatory ventilation
as well in our laparoscopic procedures
for example which allows us
to
stop the lungs
so the lungs are not expanding and
collapsing which prevents which stops
that all the organs from moving back and
forth obviously with the exception of
the heart
um but it makes allows us to
perform a procedure
easier and be more precise as well
so why wouldn't you monitor your animals
um i mean i think there's a lot of
obviously good reasons at least i think
so while we should monitor mice and rats
but the main reason for that that we're
not is that the expense at least that's
the feedback that we usually get
however when we think about
overall our projects and complete
clinical studies
do we perform
that investment is
worthwhile i hope i have convinced you
here that it's really worthwhile and if
we're implementing all this
physiological monitoring or anesthesia
monitoring in larger species we perform
similar procedure
there's really no justification why you
would not provide that
type of monitoring with rodents
and when we implement it
we're going to have well conducted
studies which is going to allow us to
standardize our procedures which
in the long run allows us to reproduce
these studies not just between labs
but not just i'm sorry within the lab
but also between the labs and facilities
so
that's one of the ways we can actually
decrease the number of these studies
which just showed the animal studies are
poor predictors
due to poorly performed procedures
so the take-home point
i hope that i have
convinced you here is that you want to
consider what anesthetics to use
and utilize veterinary judgment for that
um you also have to have knowledge of
the research study needs what you're
performing but really on the inhalant
energy anesthetics
are
appropriate
for all the reasons that we talked about
and in the end though if you can utilize
inhalation aesthetics with addition of
injectables
like buprenorphy for example it provides
a better uh
anesthetic
and decreases a lot of the variables you
know we don't have the time to really go
into that here but if you have to select
between one or the other really uh the
inhaling and aesthetics are
are more appropriate
you also have to consider the effects of
anesthetics on research data that we
discussed
so incorporating physiological
anesthesia monitoring it's better for
the patients
it's better for the data that we're
collecting
but
you have to remember that do not rely
only on one
single parameter
or only on a physiological monitoring
obviously the clinical monitoring is
also important
so combining both
and relying on multiple parameters is
really the way you should monitor the
animals
so when we incorporate
all of these
we're going to have well-conducted
studies
which is again allow us to standardize
and reproduce our studies and it's going
to lead to higher translation into
clinics and overall it's going to lead
to better
or higher animal
welfare and again that's one of the big
reasons why we're all here
so now i'll be happy to
take any questions if there are any but
also i want to thank you guys for
attending this conference as well as
attending this session
and again if you have any questions you
can utilize the q a
chat
i believe it's on your left hand side
there
so
um while you guys are thinking of
questions i just want to use my contact
information and if you think of anything
after the conference uh please feel free
to email me i'll be more than happy to
uh
to try to help you with that
so one of the questions i couldn't see
all your presentation are you going to
post some information after
um so yes so we are going to provide you
with the file to download i know it's
not in uh
available there yet but it will be
posted later on today so you will have
the pdf file
there if you need it immediately like
right now i just again please send me an
email on the address that you have there
i'll be more than happy to forward it to
you
um one of the question it was what is uh
with
experience against propofol with uh with
mice um
so
it's something that actually when i did
my
residency at university of washington we
tried it using it ip and obviously now
you guys i think i'm well aware of that
it doesn't work well it introduces just
a lot of different complications um so
one of so we have we have not been using
it
at this stage but one of the things that
we are thinking about is that right now
for all of our mice and rats when we
perform
longer procedures
a lot of the procedures actually we
throw in iv catheters to provide warm uh
saline throughout the procedure uh
intravascularly
so with now getting into that and doing
that on a repetitive basis
propofol might be something that we
are actually thinking about trying
so i'm sorry i don't have a an answer
for you here but i'm hoping that maybe
next year at this conference we'll be
able to share that data and information
with you
so what is the name of the blue dye you
used to monitor where injections were
given so again that was the blue
um ethylene blue dye
do you have experience with densel
flooring at my facility we are switching
to sibo from iso but should we consider
it daiso flooring so unfortunately i do
not have experience with them
with the this of this flooring
and
it's something that we have been
thinking about as well uh but currently
after you spent quite a bit of time uh
comparing isoflowering to sibo fluorine
and that's what we've switched to uh but
it's something that
if there's other folks out there please
let us know
but we are going to be
doing more studies and comparisons this
year on that
and a good person actually to ask that
would be uh paul fleck now
so again the person that asked me about
the discipline if you can email me at
this address i'll be more than happy to
connect with both blacknell and i think
he has done some uh work with with this
employment
it sounds like you have a surgical core
which utilizes this equipment what about
individual labs
uh do they utilize this equipment do you
train
them so yes we so one yes we do we do
train people we have hands on workshops
here uh but we also recommend actually
for us travel to your facilities to do
that because then we can assess your
whole surgical setup
and training and equipment that you have
available there
and
until just recently i'd say within the
last year or at least two years or so
there's a lot of
individual
scientists that do not utilize the
equipment or utilize monitoring
but that's changing again because of all
the different aspects that we're seeing
that we can decrease the confounding
factors with it
and
a lot of also
at institutions are now
the lab animal cores are actually
purchasing equipment so they can share
between
the labs but again when you think of the
cost of the equipment then when you
compare it to
all of your other costs even if you
compare just to the number or you know
the cost of the animals that you utilize
it's really relatively inexpensive and
it's really worthwhile to to purchase
what physiological monitoring equipment
would you recommend for batch
rodent studies
so for that
for us again we use the can't scientific
equipment so we have them at each
station um so
um i know that gets
ends up being uh
can be pretty uh you know financially uh
challenging to obtain but one the
advantage of those units are very small
it provides you with the recording
of it and you can actually visualize as
a screen where you can monitor the
animals
so
if you're doing multiple
animals at the same time again we would
recommend actually having units
per animal i'm not aware of any units
that would
provide you with that type of
information that you can utilize one
unit for multiple animals
and i hope that addresses your question
if i answered your question please
let me know
in a question
here
when you talk about batch
surgeries
so
good afternoon in your opinion what
factors should be considered for the use
of ketamine
xylazine intravenously
uh thank you
uh for for the conference so
i think that's a great that's a great
question and it's also really
great to hear that you are using it
intravenously versus utilizing ip or
subcutaneously um
but what we would really recommend is
um
doing the monitoring for what we just
what i described here for the
cardiovascular system your respiratory
system
um
and so you can do that and doing a pilot
study that's one of the things that
we very often do with the different
procedures
especially when you have something like
a mixture of ketamine and anxiety so
again just monitoring the basics
for the cardiovascular
and
in the respiratory
system
and the temperature obviously as
well so have you used
the xdometer and then antecedent and
rodents if so what are your thoughts and
did it work well so here um dr vince
mendenhall his group actually uses that
uh quite quite a bit and
paul fleck nels groups also does
and for us when we use that uh
a few times it works excellent it works
really really well uh the animals
obviously wake up sooner
so the recovery period is shorter
so if you are going to use injectables
it's something that
i would definitely definitely recommend
and using a reversible with injectables
is really really important um so that
does work
those work quite well
thank you for that question
and by rodents also just to clarify uh
this was in mice and rats i don't have
experience with
this and other
and other species
okay well thank you so much for up
there's another
question i think
have you
how are you informing others pis lab
managers of these new units drugs new
equipment and i'd wake as with most
research groups do not hear about these
items
i think that's an excellent excellent
question
and because when you educate folks about
them it's really um a lot of pis world
just on their own implemented but that
is a challenge so for example at wake
forest
we work with the icook here and we run
obviously the adventure we are on our
workshops here
but what we found is that the best way
to do that if you can
is actually doing a one day workshop
where in the morning we spend half a day
of didactic where you just talk about
this
and the advantages and then in the
afternoon demonstrate
you know the changes that you will see
with this equipment um and especially
just when you anesthetize the mice or
the rats when you have this
physiological equipment
just a simple thing like the drop in
temperature um i mean when the pi see
that i mean seeing their
expression i mean it's just really
priceless uh when you know the drop
happens you know within minutes two to
three degrees uh but it it is
challenging so one of the things what
we're trying to do
and is actually to pull in a consortium
of different groups and companies uh
where we could actually
um almost having like setting up uh
you know
a travel bus to
to teach people about this but again i
think working with your icook is really
important
and providing this one day workshop
would be really ideal
and also when you do those providing
with different types of units because
again different pi's are going to need
different have different needs
um but but it is it is challenging um
to to provide you know how do you
implement that but one of the other
things that's really important is that
at your institution you have to have
support from folks
above or on top there
to do that
as well it's really really important
what kind of anesthesia would you choose
just to immobilize mice
to uh
to inhale
a substance so
that's a great question and and so
depending what you know how long do you
need the animals to be anesthetized and
that's something that if you can answer
uh
add that to your question
but again you can actually utilize gas
anaesthetics so one of the things that
we're trying now is actually
just nasal intubation and doing uh
10 seconds so you can for example if you
go with uh with with isofluorine
i think you get between five
um five to ten seconds of anesthesia and
then you can
introduce your substance so
we are really big proponents of
inhalable anesthetics because pretty
much any injectable that you're going to
introduce or potentially iv like
propofol
that might be another
an option that again we're going to be
trying that out this year but anything
else that you introduced to the animals
you're going to have a significant
anesthetic period which for a 10 second
procedure is really not worthwhile so i
would just try utilizing your
your gas anesthesia and then also
depending how you introducing um your uh
you know the substance uh maybe you can
utilize uh
you know the the nostril uh want to
anesthetize the animal and be able to
introduce your and that's something that
we have tried
as well
interference with
interference with substance inflammation
and along
um so what kind of
so i'm sorry i'm not understand if you
could clarify that for me the
interference with substance
inflammation in the lung
so i'm sorry i don't um if you could
clarify that for me ob and would have to
try to answer that question
what anesthesia protocol would you use
for the parkinson's disease mouse model
6ohda so i'm sorry i don't have
experience with
with that model
um so and i'm not familiar with that
model either
so unfortunately i won't be able to to
answer that
the question for you specifically
but again with that if
please email me the question and uh i
there's usually um in our group or with
the groups that we talk about in
aesthetics there's someone that might be
able to answer that for for for me so i
can forward it to you or connect
connection with them
so if you wouldn't mind sending me an
email with the question i'll be more
than happy to try to identify someone
that has that experience
so i mean do you think there are
important influences and substances
to
inhale
get that question here i mean do you
think there are important influences and
substances to inhale
and isoflura
okay so if i'm understanding the
question would the substances are being
inhaled would there interfere with
the isofluorine the gas understands
you're providing again that's a great
question
and
even with inflammation i guess that you
could
you could introduce there um
one of the things that again we would
recommend is just doing a pilot study
which you can address very quickly
what's going to happen there
but if you're introducing your compound
again the anesthetic period is so short
that
most likely that wouldn't again
have an effect on at least the
anesthesia aspect
would that have an interaction with your
compound that you're doing potentially
could
but then also if you're introducing a
compound if you
go into intravenous or injectable
anesthetics no could they interact
together as well that's something to
consider
so again we're really big proponents of
doing pilot studies
you know just on a few animals and that
would
address the question
that you have
and so to kind of
continue with that
theme there is that also there one of
the things that
we
do quite a bit is just do a search for
the compound the potential you're
working with or something similar to the
compound that you're working with i know
the potential components are proprietary
but most likely there's something
similar that someone is working
and so if you do the pubmed as searches
and even if the information is not in
the publication
just actually reaching out to the
authors uh is is really
can be very helpful
do you see any case of latent
hyperthermia and rodents
as you do with dogs
excellent
excellent question
and
in
all of that
surgical procedures that we have done we
have not seen that uh but i will be very
interested to hear back from other folks
there
um if you have uh and it what an
aesthetic that you use then
what studies
but we have not seen that that's an
excellent
question so there's another question do
you have experience using s ketamine
instead of archetamine and ip injection
anesthesia combined with xylazine
so it's an excellent question and
unfortunately i do not i think that
question actually came out also
yesterday
um with uh dr uh marcel peregentio who
gave a presentation
um and so i can follow up with him to
see if he was able to identify someone
that has experience with that
but unfortunately um i do i do not
and again from the audience uh if you
have experience with it please email me
so i can pass it on to uh
to balaz
from australia thank you for joining us
oh i'm sorry austria
so
there's another question coming in
well so i don't see any more questions
coming in but again if you think of
something please email me
and again if um
we're more than happy to try to address
those for you and if we don't know the
answer or if i don't know the answer
i apologize i could address some of the
questions you guys have today which are
really good questions and i'll be more
to happy to try to identify someone who
could
help you out with those questions
so again thank you so much for joining
me here
and for a participle in this up there's
another question
how important the three hours of
research reduction refinement and
replacement of random one research
has influenced
the stem cell research
um so i think
that's a that's a really good question
um and so one of that um
when i was at the university of
washington
um
i actually worked with uh with human
embryonic stem cells we have also
established canine embryonic stem cells
and with rodents as well and and so
obviously that's a very broad field
but for us for example one of the things
is teratoma formation
which when is utilized to
check for pluripotency of stem cells and
very often the way that has been done is
that
you actually do uh open surgical
procedure
and inject them into that kidneys
or test these and they test these for
example a lot of times it's not an open
procedure but you just end up
doing kind of blindly you hold the
testes and then you inject your cells in
there so you don't really visualize
exactly where they go
so what we have done we actually utilize
laparoscopic
uh
procedure to do that
so we are able to really easily
visualize where the cells are going um
into the testes for example kidneys
liver
or spleen
but the other big advantage with that
refinement is that i can go in and a
week later um or you know five six seven
days later and actually see if those
specific stem cells are actually
starting to form a teratoma
so if they are great we continue with
the study if they're not then we end up
you know
euthanizing these animals and uh and
moving forward with our project so we
can save us time
and
with these laparoscopic procedures we
can do that with one to two millimeter
incisions and which is almost you know
like using a large
needle so
from our experience that's one of the
refinements that we have introduced
which again
allow you to decrease the number of
animals they end up utilizing
and refining it by not holding the
animals for such a long period of time
as you have done um in the past
so again it's one of those things
there's a lot of other refinements in
that arena you know the idea of you know
should we actually do tautoma testing
anymore um uh and in animals uh to test
blurbiness or not um but um
but this is one of the refinements the
other refinement that we have introduced
is
never introduced i mean has been around
but not really
applied in the lab animal medicine is
the high frequency
oscillatory uh ventilation
which again allows you to really stop
the lungs
from moving so if i'm utilizing want to
inject stem cells into the heart when
i'm doing thoracic procedure
by stopping the lungs i can be very
precise where i'm injecting
them into the heart again heart is
moving but um at this point we have not
identified
a procedure that would be able to stop
the heart if someone else there has
suggestions we're happy to hear and try
those
but again
utilizing the high frequency acetoid
ventilation for thoracic procedures
working with stem cells has been very uh
very very useful
so it's another question story really
quick what about
kitty magic dextomator salazine and
buprenex uh would that be too much in
mice and rats that's a fantastic
question
and that's something that
again you're going to have to try with
different strains that you're working
with
utilizing that in rats
we found that
with the
buprenor buprenex they really knock out
especially the dosages that are commonly
recommended really knocks out
the animals and it's also going to
depend what kind of procedures are you
doing are you doing uh
ortho orthopedic
procedures
or something that's involved with the
gastrointestinal tract
it's going to have an impact on that on
those animals as well
so with the buprenex what we found is
that utilizing a
lower dose
of what's usually recommended half that
dose or even maybe a quarter of that
um
is has worked better for us um but again
you're going to have to really just try
it and test it
especially if you're working with a
model the potential has now been really
published a lot about with this type of
anaesthetics
and
again working with paul flacknell he
really recommends utilizing multiple
agents
but with that
so you end up having a balanced uh
anesthesia but at the same time you are
going to have to test those
and just like with i guess with any
other agents as well
because i think one of the things that
we're now doing is actually over
anesthetizing the animals we have done
there with gas anesthetics for a long
time just by you know using that one
liter and 2.5
uh percent isofluorine um and that's not
always necessary um so it's the same
thing with an injectables that i think a
lot of times we uh over anesthetize the
animals uh when it's not really even
with analgesics same thing
but one of the things they did not
mention is that
you really also have to monitor the amps
as individuals not as a herd and i know
that's going to be challenging if you
have a large study
but again if you really wanted to see
and refine your studies and decrease the
number of animals you're going to use
you really have to implement the same
things we do with larger species to
rodents we're talking about surgical
procedures
it's certainly true for us with the
gastric bypass procedures where we did
actually
we have to monitor the animals on an
individual basis and we found that the
analgesics even in the same strain
um in its in different individuals
require different dosages of the
synaptics
and it's very common with the diabetic
rats at least in our in our experience
so i hope that addresses your your
question
you see this i don't think there's any
more questions so
again i want to thank you one more time
for attending the session and the
conference and also i want to mention
that please go visit the sponsor the
vendor hall
because again we could not have this
conference without uh their support as
you know there's no registration fee for
this conference so we rely very heavily
on um
on the sponsor so please visit the spot
the sponsor hall you can check out
different things there's a lot of new
things coming out especially when you're
talking about physiological monitoring
uh so kent scientific is there with us
um as well so you can see actually some
of the equipment i have some i think
videos as well
um
so anyway
uh thank you so much again for attending
the session and please enjoy the rest of
the conference thank you so much guys